[Music]
this week on Q&A author and Hoover
institutions senior fellow Thomas soul
he recently ended his syndicated column
which he had for 25 years and he talks
about his life and career and his love
of photography
[Music]
dr. Thomas Sol you wrote this at the end
of 2016 age 86 is well past the usual
retirement age so the question is not
why I am quitting but why I kept at it
so long why did you why did I keep at it
so long yes sir there were a lot of
things happening I thought Auto be
explained in a different way from there
explained and what and most of the media
and I enjoy doing it I enjoyed hearing
back from people I was sorry that I
never had a chance to reply to them all
which would have taken up every all the
time I have I have your last column and
there I'm going to add just ask you why
you put this in the column and you can
expand on it if you would like my own
family did not have electricity or a hot
running water in my early childhood
which was not unusual for blacks in the
south in those days what do you remember
about those days and where was it in the
south oh well I remember a lot because I
I didn't didn't leave the South until I
was almost nine years old and so I spent
a fair amount of time down there and
most of those places there was no hot
running hot running water and we had
cold water which many other blacks in
those days did not have by the way but
it's it's so it's sort of says where I
came from you moved to Harlem but what
was that like and who did you live with
in Harlem
oh I lived with the same family that had
raised me in North Carolina some members
had gone up ahead and had been in New
York for a year or so I think before we
got there
and fortunately for me they ran into a
boy named Eddie who was quite unusual
and for those days he was highly you
came from a highly educated family was
obviously very cultured fellow and so
before I ever arrived in New York they
had decided that this was someone I
needed to meet because he could tell me
things that they themselves did not have
the education to tell me and that this
could help me in life
now at the time I myself was not by any
means looking ahead that way but the
birds thought but thank heavens others
were where is Eddie today and what did
he do in his life well you know uh
ironic last year when I on my birthday I
received a card from him he's a he's a
year older than I am he when he went on
to become the Dean of one of the
colleges and he's now retired living in
a very nice area so it was it was quite
a pleasant surprise
but my life really could have been very
different had had I not been introduced
to him and I would never have been
introduced to him except that members of
my family older I saw immediately that
this was someone who could be helpful to
me he and I never lived within a quarter
mile of each other and he was a year
older so I would never have been in the
same class with him in school but he was
able to tell me things that I didn't
know for example he took me to a public
library for the first time in my life
and at the time I had no idea what a
public library was and was really very
dubious when I saw all those books and
realized I didn't have enough money to
buy one of them but he patiently
explained it all to me and persuaded me
somewhat reluctantly to take out a
library card and and and borrow a couple
of books and that was anonymously
important because it meant that I began
to acquire the habit of reading on my
own you know years before I ever would
have acquired the normal course of
events what kind of books were you
interested in in those early days oh
heavens I remember reading the old
children's books you know dr. Dolittle
eyes Alice in Wonderland stuff like that
but the main thing was that I read and
read and we eventually simply got the
habit of reading other kids from the
same neighborhood in which I grew up
with you know odds were against their
ever meeting someone like that it was as
they were for me except that others saw
the significance of introducing
how long did you live in Harlan oh I
until 19th I was 20 I was 20 years old
before you the first time I moved out of
Harlem and then I came back for a couple
of years so I grew up there from the
time from the age of just before I was 9
years old
so besides Eddie what impact did Harlem
and your family experience have on you
other than you know the library oh I
think a tremendous effect I didn't
realize it at the time for example I
when I was much older and had us at a
son of my own like most first-time
parents I wanted to know one easy
supposed to do various things and so I
asked one of the surviving members of
the family how old was I when I first
began to walk and she said Oh Tommy
nobody knows when you could walk
somebody was always carrying you and I
was raised you know as an only child and
a family of four adults so you know
whenever I got to be too much for one of
them he get all he or she could always
hand it all and me off to somebody else
and I remember one episode in particular
there was recounted many times in later
years that birdy a member of the family
so it took me to a movie and everything
went fine it was on a different part of
town it was only when we got back and I
saw the house where we lived I picked up
some rocks and started throwing them at
birdy
I must have been four years old at the
most and in later years she would tell
that story and just laughed and you know
I was a little angel until until I got
back there and I said let him much later
years I thought you know yeah you can
take that attitude when there's one
child and four adults if it's the other
way around one mother and four children
it wouldn't have been nearly as funny
you know you we've talked before and you
always mentioned that you like to think
things through before you either write a
book or you write a column and you're
not in any hurry to
those published how about this final
column how long did you think that
through and what kind of a message is
you want to leave at the end well I did
two final ones like but I don't think I
took any longer than with then and then
with the others I mean these were
thingies the thoughts I'd had I had
thoughts of not renewing my contract in
some previous years but my wife always
told me that you know you're the very
least you can blow off steam when you
and things that happen in the world it's
you know that you don't like but I this
particular time I was off taking
pictures in Yosemite with some
photographic buddies of mine the four
days and in all that time I never
watched the television news program we
never read a newspaper and I thought
this is the way to live and the only way
to live this way is to stop writing the
column so that I don't have to be up up
the date on all the news and that's the
biggest benefit that when I'm watching a
television program and the some
silliness in politics comes on the air I
can simply switch to the tennis channel
order all the Turner Classic Movies or
just turn the thing off because I feel
no obligation now to keep track of
things like that and they say and those
kind of things certainly don't do my
blood pressure or any good you're now
sitting on the Stanford campus in Palo
Alto
do you remember when you had your first
solid political thought or idea
oh yes heavens I was 10 years old and it
wasn't really my idea it's what I had
heard and I had heard that that Wilkie
was for the rich and FDR was for the
poor and so my first political activism
was going around tearing down will keep
Oh stirs in Harlem fortunately they
weren't that many will keep posters in
Harlem and so I didn't waste a great
deal of time on that were you did you
consider yourself a Democrat
I don't know if well at that time I was
a long way from voting age but most of
my I was a registered Democrat as late
as 1970s spring of 1972 and for the last
time and since then I've never been a
registered member of any party on that
particular year I was so disgusted with
both candidates that I didn't vote at
all and neither of those candidates
seemed to be as bad and in retrospect as
the two candidates we had last year let
me go back to the column and ask you
about this paragraph years of lying
presidents you're talking about could
any president do anything like that
today meaning it was John F Kennedy
you've been writing about and and they
have a Soviet Union and the trust that
people had in the president then but you
say then years of lying Democrat Lyndon
Johnson and Republican Richard Nixon
especially destroyed not only their own
credibility but the credibility which
the office itself once conferred the
loss of that credibility was a loss to
the country not just to the people
holding that office in later years
why did you consider both Johnson and
Nixon presidencies as lying presidencies
well Nix is the easiest one I mean he
lied obviously about Watergate but I but
in retrospect I think the fact that
Nixon was so obviously lying I regard is
almost a virtue that is when you slam on
television of saying things that were
turned out and proved to be false you
could see him sweating and so forth I
mean you didn't take any great the
insight to know that he was lying even
before the evidence came out with Lyndon
Johnson my gosh there were so many
things he said he got us into this and
the Gulf of Tonkin Resolution later on
later off turned out to have been fed by
something there was a completely
overblown in order to give him a power
to go to war but at the crucial time in
that war after the Tet Offensive of 1968
the media all said that this
uprising of communist guerrillas in
South Vietnam will show that our
policies had failed that their that the
Communists had won it so happens that
later evidence including statements by
communist leaders themselves after the
economy Vietnam was that the American
troops had actually wiped out the
Vietcong guerrillas in South Vietnam and
and that they were never a serious force
thereafter but what came through the
media was that the via the Viet Cong
guerrillas had succeeded that they had
inflicted a terrible loss on Americans
and that the war was unwinnable now if
the public thinks the war is unwinnable
that will in fact make it unwinnable and
Lyndon Johnson came on the air told the
truth perhaps a rare thing for him and
yet he was not believed and all those in
the media who are putting forth what
turned out to be completely false
stories were believed and therefore all
the 50,000 Americans who lost their
lives in Vietnam winning victory after
victory
all of that would went down the tubes
because the president didn't have
credibility when he needed it what's
been the impact of the Vietnam War and
the Watergate years on this country
oh no no question a a great cynicism
about the public if I may go back to
John F Kennedy in 1962 at the Cuban
Missile Crisis now I was never a big fan
of President Kennedy and he he won very
narrowly in 1960 but when he came on the
air and told us that the Russians were
going to put nuclear missiles 90 miles
the United States and that he was taking
us to the brink of nuclear war to stop
them I thought you know he's president I
mean he's got to do what he's got to do
and it was a very very tense time I was
teaching at the time and I remember when
I was giving out the assignment to the
students in class I said you know the
assignment for next week and I had to
bite my tongue to keep from saying if
there is a next week I know but that was
there was that kind
of confidence I don't recall anybody
raising any fuss with this man for
taking this step that really could have
been the death of millions as he well
knew today I don't think any President
of the United States in the last 3040
years could go on the air and do that
and have the public behind him and
that's not not a problem for him that's
a problem for the country if you have a
president he has to have the public
support not for his sake but for the
public seat
do you remember how you felt about
Watergate in the middle of it all yes
someone was trying to get me to accept a
presidential appointment in the Nixon
administration and they asked me to send
me send them my visa and I said you know
I have to tell you in order to prevent
you from being embarrassed that I'm very
just heard about what's coming out about
Watergate and at some point I may find
it necessary to criticize the president
of United States and the guy at the
White House said to me Tom if we if we
let that stop us we never will get these
jobs Phil Phil send us your resume and
what you do know I decided I didn't want
the job anyway you know what you're on
that I we've got some video of you back
in our talk in 2005 talking about an
offer you had in the Ford administration
and as people listen to this they have
to keep in mind when you're telling this
story that there was a Democratic Senate
at that time let's listen to this and
you'll see what you said back in 2005
which president offered you the federal
trade commissioners job
President Ford what were the
circumstances they had a vacancy it was
it was 1976 and they offered it to me
and I agreed to take it on condition
that if there's any opposition to arises
they let me know I'll withdraw because I
don't have time to play Washington games
and I kept calling the air and asking
and the guy at the White House was
handling this
sorry bro I don't hear anything what's
going on and he said oh no no it's just
taking time eventually I was in
Washington so I went up to the hill and
talked to the staffer of this committee
that handle this and he said we've gone
over your record with a fine-tooth comb
we can find nothing to object to and
therefore we're just not gonna hold
hearings because this is an election
year we expect that guy's gonna be
elected and he'll appoint his own man
what burned me was that he said not and
I said you teach all the white houses he
said we told the White House this months
ago and would you have taken that job ad
they cleared you and the Senate are you
mean after know after learning this yeah
well no I mean if it process had moved
faster hadn't you agreed to go to the
Federal Trade Commission yes I I would
have reluctantly but some in fact the
first time it was offered to me I said
no but they came back again and in the
meantime someone whom I knew said Tom
you got you're always criticizing the
Federal Trade Commission here is your
chance to be one of the commissioners
and I thought you know I really should
then so I would have taken it but it was
not something I look forward to it meant
moving they did then it did not mean any
increase in pay but it did mean an
increase in cost of living and so on so
I mean many downsides for me personally
but I thought that really as a matter of
living up to what I've been saying I
ought to go and try it now your first
job in government though was
considerably earlier than that and what
was it oh I was the gs2 clerk and the
General Accounting Office back in 1950
and that was a big step up for me at the
time that means that you were at gs2
they started just one and go up to GS 18
I know they still do 18 but they did the
senior executive service why had you
gone in the government and what impacted
those years have on your thinking today
well you mean the years before or the
year after we used afterwards yeah after
you had had the experience of working in
the government it was not habit-forming
there was a lot of double-dealing and
stuff going on but by that by the time
this this is before I was drafted and
went into the Marine Corps but after I
came out I can't went back eventually to
that job but now I I realized I had the
GI Bill to back me up and that I was now
try to go to college and so I never
regarded that as a career thing I I just
it was something I would do and that
gave me a great deal of freedom because
for one thing there's one example of the
freedom back in those days the General
Accounting Office had a large unit that
was essentially all-black and it was
presided over a white woman from Georgia
and they had different rules that when
other units if you were late you signed
a t4 tardy but in the unit that I was in
if you were late they they docked you a
hours annual leave and you had you sign
for it since I was planning to leave it
when I got it when the time was right
and I was gonna turn in my annual leave
for money I was not about to sign for
that for that and I told him quite
frankly that not only was I not going to
sign that if they took the leave without
my signing I would take the case right
after the Civil Service Commission they
immediately realized that they knew they
were wrong to begin with but they
realized if I did that you know all hell
would break loose and so and then one of
those wonderful political compromises
they would let me sign a tea for Tory
and everybody else had to sign for at
for an hour's annual leave and that
deprived me of any standing to bring any
case I told the others but they wouldn't
believe me many of them felt I must have
some secret in I must know somebody or
something but that was the way it was
the other thing was the other people
were career civil servants and so they
they they knew not to make waves I
really didn't care because I wasn't
playing to be there that long did you
ever ask anybody then why in the world
they would have to separate you know
ideas about when somebody was late why
they would do one with the whites one
with the blacks no because I mean it's I
I think if you put a white woman from
Georgia in the 1950s in charge were
black Union that's what you expect to
happen in and talking about your last
words that you wrote at least in your
columns for was a creative services
creative creative Creators Syndicate
syndicate I'm sorry you say the first
column I ever wrote 39 years ago and
this is you wrote at the end of 2016 was
titled the prophets of doom this was
long before Al Gore made millions of
dollars promoting global warming
hysteria back in 1970 the preventing
hysteria was the threat of new Ice Age
promoted by some of the same
environmentalists who are promoting
global warming hysteria today do you I
tried to find that column on the
internet it's not there that I could
find is it available for any of us to
read yes it was published in the old
Washington stall which is you know about
went out of business some years ago
hopefully not as a result of my columns
but there's a book called pink and brown
people which is the first collection of
my columns that was published by the
Hoover Institution back in early 1980s
and in it sits in there well whether
whether that book is still in print I do
I don't know but did you go but when you
wrote your last columns you go back and
read it no I did not well but I
remembered it because it was my first
column and I had no thought when I wrote
it that I would be writing regularly the
Washington stall had a feature where
ordinary readers could write in and send
in a column and I sent that that was the
first time I ever tried it and and they
published it as I wrote it and so that
was the beginning your undergraduate
degree was from what school Harvard we
started at Howard and then went to
Harvard that's right your master's
degree was from Columbia yes and then
your PhD at Chicago
what was your dissertation about oh it
was called says-- law and historical
analysis and in fact I wrote a very
expanded version of that dissertation as
a book published by Princeton University
Press I counted I got on Amazon and
counted the number of and just very
quickly kind of the number of
opportunities to buy something with your
name on it and I think I stopped at 57
but I know those are all kinds of things
including essays but how many actual
books have you've completed since you
started writing them oh my goodness you
know I've been asked that question I've
never actually counted them partly
because it depends on what you mean
there are books that are original books
they're books to the collections of
previous writings and so on and they're
monographs and so forth but I've never
really tried to keep track but it's it's
a few dozen at this point which one of
the all those books so the most Oh
having this basic economics that only
sells the most in English has been
translated into seven or eight languages
what would you say would be the most
important thing and I know this is a
simple question most important thing are
things that people who read that book
will learn oh my gosh that is tough but
I guess they'll learn what economics is
all about which which is more more than
just the sum of other of the topics and
in the first chapter I point out that
economics really I you elaborate on a
definition from London School of
Economics that economics is the study of
scarce resources which have alternative
uses in other words there was no
economics in the Garden of Eden because
everything was available
you know unlimited unlimited quantities
but I think in thinking generally
whether an economics otherwise too many
people do not begin by saying what are
the inherent constraints of the
situation we're talking about and and
they act as if you know their God on the
first day of creation
and can follow whatever policy seems to
them best you know but by the time when
each of us enters a world it is already
completely elaborated and complex before
we ever got here and so you make your
decisions within that context and if you
don't think of it that way
you can have all sorts of utopian
notions to get one obvious example I
hear from time to time people complain
you know that George Washington Thomas
Jefferson condone to condone slavery
slavery was there for centuries before
George Washington and Thomas Jefferson
were ever born and neither of them
thought that the office of the
presidency had any powers to do anything
about it
Lincoln was able to do something about
it because he did so not simply as
president but as the commander-in-chief
in a war and what he did applied only to
people who were in rebellion against the
United States but there was no basis
otherwise and so they if you can't think
in terms of what were the things
confronting the people who made
decisions if nothing is easier than to
sit sit there today and say oh this
should have been done that should have
been done and that's not taking the past
as it was it's it's treating the past as
if it's just the present taking place in
earlier times and that is not the case
when Yale University took the name John
Calhoun off of one of their buildings
what was your reaction oh my gosh by
this time I had given up all hope for
the academic world and so practically
nothing surprises me anymore if we're if
we're gonna again look retrospectively
what whatever reason his name was put on
there it was there and and I don't know
anything that has happened since then
it's make al hunain he better or any
worse than he was when that decision was
made if you're gonna go back the first
thing that you're so desperate for
grievances that you have to go back into
history to find them that really says
something we talked about the impact of
Vietnam and Watergate on the country
what about the impact of slavery on the
country
great and not in any number of ways but
the question is the thing that always
gets me is that the past whatever it is
good bad or terrible it's irrevocable
and the only thing we have any influence
over our other present and the future
and nothing that we do III was so
painless to learn that apparently Angela
Merkel in Germany felt a need to taking
these refugees in order to help Germany
live down on the terrible record of
Hitler nothing is ever gonna change what
Hitler did nothing all you can do is do
things that are gonna have an effect in
the present in the future and the
effects that her policies of having in
the present have been disastrous and
there's no reason to believe that
they're gonna be any less disastrous in
the future I want to go excuse me go
back and look at some video of you in
nineteen eighty seven testifying before
the United States Senate Judiciary
Committee about Robert Bork it's about
thirty Seconds this may be the most
important Supreme Court nomination of
our time not simply because the present
court is so closely divided or even
because judge Bork is the most highly
qualified nominee of this generation but
because this is an historic crossroads
as regards the expanding power of judges
which is to say the erosion of people's
rights to govern themselves
democratically why did you testify there
and what impacted the rejection of
Robert Bork cab on the rest of the
judiciary over the years oh my I
testified because of the gross
distortions that were coming out I would
listen I was listening to the
congressional hearings during the day
and I'd hear how Bork was if it's very
least racially insensitive or actually
opposed to civil rights and so forth and
then I would go to the Stanford Law
Library and and and check out judge
bork's Iraq
and his record before he became a judge
and I discovered and in those files
amicus Correa uh papers filed by Judge
Bork repeatedly on the side of black
civil rights organization I learned that
no civil rights advocate had ever lost
the case in judge box court and I was
already familiar with with walks record
before he even before I even looked into
the law because I was teaching economics
and I often read things that he wrote
about antitrust law which which were
brilliant things and so enormous Lee
intelligent man an enormous Lee decent
man and all sorts of utter filth was
brought up one being for example that he
had he that he worked for big
corporations you see because when he was
more important to him and Bork was that
was an academic which is not a big big
bucks enterprise to get rich quick uh
and a government official off which the
same could be said and for at the
particular time he went to work at a
high salary and business his wife was
dying of cancer and he wanted to have
the money to make her last a days as
comfortable that he possibly could and
for that to be turned in to enter into
some kind of cheap political charge was
just truly despicable more than more
than that the difference of one man on a
Supreme Court is divided is enormous and
every time I read in an opinion by Judge
Anthony Justice Anthony Kennedy that is
wishy-washy and and incoherent some
cases I think that that's the price of
defeating judge Bork
so because he was sent into replacement
what else do you what do you what do you
is your take on the Supreme Court today
just as an institution after in all
these years
oh it's very dicey and when what's dicey
are the freedoms that depend upon
whether the courts and forced the
Constitution or whether they go off on
their own social adventures I I think
the greatest disappointment with this
court
was just Chief Justice Roberts
disregarding the Tenth Amendment and
finding some terribly clever way of
evading it and declaring Obamacare
constitutional you know the Tenth
Amendment says that the government has
only such powers that are specific the
federal government has only such powers
as I specifically designated to it and
all other powers either belong to state
governments or belong to the people
themselves
there is no power for the federal
government to tell people what kind of
medical insurance they have to buy even
if they prefer something else but
because I have no idea what terribly
clever reasons the Chief Justice might
have had but what once once you knock
down the Tenth Amendment there's really
nothing the government can't order us to
do here's another clip of we talked out
in Palo Alto in 2005 and it's very brief
it's only 20 seconds and I want you to
give us your reaction to what you said
then it's the impact of 9/11 on this
country in the world oh my gosh we will
never be the same again I'm I'm
disappointed in people who seem not to
realize that it's not business as usual
anymore that it's really a core things
we have to do that we don't want to do
but the alternative is followers that
was actually 2005 and here we are twelve
years later what would you say today if
the same question was asked I think I'd
give the same answer and I be more
apprehensive today because the previous
administration is now given Iran to go
ahead to develop nuclear nuclear weapons
and Iran is testing intercontinental
missile missiles now the thing that they
they are there they're supposed to be
preparing to do is attack Israel Israel
is closer to Iran than Boston is to
Denver all right you don't need any
continental missiles to attack Israel
you need intercontinental missiles
attack people who are a quarry on
another continent and if there's not a
great mystery as to who would likely be
the target of it if they ever decided to
go that route and and I think right now
we're doing what was done by the Western
powers in the 1930s Hitler was building
up his war machine you're true you're
going from day to day and you're trying
you're taking the easy path and avoiding
the hard problems on the on the
assumption that somehow or other you
will muddle through and they've came
very close to not muddling through
France of course was conquered during
World War two sometime and one of my
columns recently may have been one of
the last ones for all I know I suggested
that people who want to understand what
is happening in the world today should
read a book called the Gathering Storm
which has which is not not about today
it's about the 1930s but once you've
seen this kind of effect 'less drifting
in the face of fatal dangers you
understand what what what kind of
thinking is going on a lack of thinking
is going on today in the way that we're
approaching the kinds of dangers we're
facing now which are far worse most
people don't understand that for the
first three years of World War two the
Western powers never won a single battle
literally either in Europe or in Asia
they were beaten time and time again
because the pacifists had gotten their
way in the 1930s and prevented an
adequate buildup of military forces for
which men paid their lives and then in
those early years of World War two
fortunately at some point the West
learned they learned their lesson the
United States entered and with
tremendous productive capacity was able
to supply itself Britain and the Soviet
Union with the power of the weapons
needed to defeat the Nazis and later the
Japanese you but we're not gonna have
that kind of time in a nuclear war
you're not gonna have three years to
muddle around and get beaten and then
come back well you will be lucky if we
have a year to get beat and still come
back the Gathering Storm is you said in
that let
common in December was written by
Winston Churchill is there any body
today in your opinion besides what you
just said that is suggesting that we
ought to worry about the Gathering Storm
and in public life oh there are people
who give meaning that hold its own
official position yeah I mean are there
people not that I've noticed I mean yeah
you don't get you don't get to win
Winston trade rolled in one sentence and
won one century Ronald Reagan would be
the closest analogy but of course he too
is gone again we never seem to look at
what are one of the inherent constraints
within which you're operating and what
can you do within those constraints
I think of Reagan you know and when the
Soviets bill set up started building up
nuclear weapons in the Eastern Europe
pointing at Western Europe and Reagan
responded by sending in American nuclear
weapons in Western Europe pointing in
Eastern Europe people were horrified and
said his man is going to get us into a
war will be annihilated and he
fortunately he disregarded them
completely and instead of getting us
into a war he brought the Cold War to an
end
people who lived through the Cold War
with the fear of nuclear annihilation
hanging over over us all that time I
have no idea what a feat that was and he
did it without firing a single shot at
the Soviet Union but but that but you
know he was no yeah I don't think he was
ever considered for a Peace Prize you
know you don't get P a Nobel Peace Prize
for having produced peace you get a
Nobel Peace Prize for saying the kinds
of things that people who are on the
Nobel Committee think I'm going to
promote peace even though those things
such as the policies of Neville
Chamberlain the Prime Minister Britain
the 1930s said which led to war since
you've been retired for I'm writing your
column
how closely have you paid attention
what's going on in in this country in
the world oh not nearly as closely as
before none of it is truly encouraging
however well I won't say
that I think the the new administration
in Washington has some very good people
better than I think most recent
administration's have had and in the top
positions the only question is whether
the president listens to them and that
we won't we won't know until you know a
lot more time has passed I wanted Jane I
want to completely change what we're
talking about to something that you seem
to enjoy and it's important to you as
you mentioned when you took your four
days off and went to Yosemite with your
friends and did your photography how
long have you been a photographer
because you have this on your website
and we're going to show someone in a
moment but how long have you been doing
photography I took my first picture in
1950 you know and then when the results
came back from to the drugstore I was
just hooked from that point on
previously I had been thinking of
becoming an artist I used to do a lot of
sketching and so forth and so I had a
sense of you know the design and you
know all right and so on and then when I
was in the Marine Corps the Marines sent
me to the Navy's photography school at
Pensacola Naval Air Station and then
there there I got a you know
professional training in the subject and
then when I got out and I was going to
wouldn't went away to Harvard I worked
for the university news office as a
photographer in order to help pay the
bills and so it was it was the perfect
job because it was something I could do
whenever I had the time and not just a
taking of pictures but when the
photographer in charge
he always had more negatives than he had
time to print them and so if I happen to
be awake at 2:00 a.m. for some reason it
wasn't going back to sleep I could go
over to the news office let myself in
and print all the negatives that he had
sitting there on his desk and leave it
on the desk for him and tell him my time
so I'd be paid so it was just it was it
was a great job well for the audience I
can see you you can't see me and you're
not going to be able to see these
pictures
photographs but I want to throw one up
on the screen I know you've got a list
of what we're gonna look at the first
one I think is just cemani it's a is
that El Capitan that's El Capitan it was
taken with a four by five lint off
camera and probably a 75 millimeter wide
angle lens when did you take that that I
don't remember but it was it was before
I became went digital so it was probably
it was probably it towards the end of
the 1900s and the next photo is a
waterfall you remember that from oh I
think I I think it's I think it's
Yellowstone night lower yellowstone
falls in Yellowstone National Park
what this it appears to it's black and
white and how much old black and white
and then it was not Yellowstone
Yellowstone was in the oh oh I know
heavens out what that would be Yosemite
Falls in the winter I believe cause I
think the snow on the ground and how
much of what you your photography is
black and white and color you like do
you like black and white or color when
you're doing your photography I like I
like both button but when I when I was
doing film Iost of it was black and
white and now that I'm digital most of
its color a color film can be very
delicate and so when I travel with color
film I had to take along a cooler like a
plug into the car to keep it cool while
I was traveling and then I'd have to
plug it into a hotel room will outlet
when I got there because the colors will
change if you let let those at the color
film sit out in the warm weather but
fortunately with digital it doesn't make
any difference the third photo is a
young lady sitting on a chair she just
about three or four years old who do we
know who that is
I know but I'm not gonna mention her
name but she is now a retired lady when
did you take this picture well back in
the 1950s I believe Mike I'm almost
certain it was before I know I know it
but by it was probably after I went into
the Marine Corps because I I know it was
taking why no what camera I took it with
it was a bush press button and I know it
lens and so on so it was I would that
would have been in the earth still in
the early 1950s is there any way of
calculating how much you have I mean I
don't need to know the dollar amount but
if you spend a lot of money a lot of
your your extra money that you have on
photography over the years and has been
an expensive hobby it's but it's really
my only extravagance I I'm not big on
clothes or other luxury my wife doesn't
wake jewelry and stuff so this is the
only only thing I will say that when I
finally decided to go completely digital
and sold all my photographic equipment
to a local camera store they pay me over
ten thousand dollars for what was at
that time used used equipment some of it
obsolete so I must have spent it off a
lot more than that when I bought it
originally here's a photograph of kids
playing on the beach in the water
oh yes where's that so that's an that's
the Santa Monica beach in Southern
California the camera was a twin-lens
reflex called the Mamiya 330 and and I
was probably I was probably on the
boardwalk the Santa Monica boardwalk
looking down at them and I saw that
picture and just took it what what have
you done with all your photographs and
you catalogue tomorrow and you're gonna
give them to somebody no well I have
negatives I'll have a few I have a few
that are there are friends of course
most of my Iowa the ones I really like I
have hanging on the walls in my in my
home so but I have the negative is the
trend isn't a number I my first negative
in my file was taken a 1948 of people
picketing the White House when Truman
was president and over the years how
many different kinds of cameras have you
used oh my gosh at one time I had a
dozen cameras
simultaneously so this will give you
anything and has obviously been that
turnover today I I struggle along with
just six what kind of cameras now I do
most of my what my picture with pictures
with two two Nikon d3 X's and then I
have a couple of Sony cameras and a
couple of others miscellaneous here's a
photo here's a photograph of a gentleman
painting with a beret on and a cigar in
his mouth where's that
oh yes that's Greenwich Village 1952 and
the camera was a roller cord what when
you take a picture of somebody like this
do you have to get their permission to
use it I hope not because I didn't get
it here's here's a an aerial shot of it
looks like Niagara Falls and my first
question is how did you get this picture
from a helicopter
now it's sometimes I've charted a
helicopter for this just for this
purpose but in this case they happen to
be an already existing helicopter
service and so I just got it honor for
the heck of it and I flew around the
Agra Falls and I simply shot the picture
out the window have you sold any of your
photographs not really I've some of them
have been published there was a picture
I took of a lady who was a academic and
then someone did I some kind of feature
about her and they requested a copy of
this photograph I'd given it to the lady
in question and when they were
interviewing her they asked if they
could use it and so I say short go ahead
I put one on on the cover of a book of
mine fortunately unfortunate that book
was out of print inside of a year and so
that got very little exposure want to
show a photograph of the Golden Gate
Bridge and cars coming across it and
again the same question and from what
angle how did you get this photograph
well there's an observation area near
the Golden Gate Bridge and I
my Nikon d3x is and I now have a 200 to
500 millimeter telephoto and I use that
to take that pick that particular
picture what are you looking for when
you do photography I'm looking for
something that makes an interesting
scene and when I see it I simply go take
it
well one sometimes I pre plan out and
looking through old pictures of
Yellowstone National Park before I ever
went there I saw a picture of the lower
Yellowstone fold I thought my gosh I'm
sure that I'm sure I could take that
picture better than that
and when I went there I up and I think I
did take a better picture than that my
wife tells me that I was there for two
hours fortunately she brought along a
large book to read as she does on these
occasions but I was amazed when she told
me I'd been there two hours because it
what I took the Paquette picture for
every conceivable position with every
conceivable camera and lens combination
how long have you been married and where
did you meet your wife
I've been married 36 years and I like to
say that I got my wife because of
affirmative action that I had written
I'd written an article about affirmative
action which she read and in Palo Alto
and she complained to a mutual friend
that she really objected to what I had
said and thought I was wrong he said
well you know he's right here in Palo
Alto why don't the two of you get
together for lunch and work out your
differences well we got together for
lunch we have not worked out our
differences to this day but things took
I took a turn in other directions does
she agree with you politically at all a
lot of things but of course no no wives
and husbands agree on all things would
it be your advice after all these years
of marriage where you married somebody
didn't have the exact political views
how do you deal with it oh heavens I'm
not one of those people that thinks that
you go you go but
because someone did the thing
differently than you do
My heavens no no that doesn't make it's
pathetic that people nowadays think that
the fact that they disagree with
somebody is a reason to go creating a
riot and destroying property eyes at
Berkeley just recently latest among any
number of similar incidents across the
country we have one last photograph and
that is an aerial view that you took of
Stanford University right where you are
now from what angle where were you when
you took this picture I was in a
helicopter that I chartered and we
simply flew over the flew over the
campus and took it outside took the
pictures and after obviously a handheld
camera that tower like was that tower we
see is the Hoover Institution or yes it
is now yeah you've been there how long
since 1980 which would be oh my heaven
30 of my gosh it's about 36 years plus
37 years but how is how is Stanford
changed since you've been on that campus
you know I am one of the least informed
persons you could have found on what
goes on in the Stanford campus I took
the job at the Hoover Institution rather
than another job that was offered to me
back east
mainly because by this time I was
thoroughly disgusted with the academic
world I was not but now I never plan to
teach again and the Hoover Institution
was the perfect place for me because he
would allow me a place where I could do
the work that I wanted to do and
research and writing and so on and have
absolutely nothing to do with the rest
of the campus and that's been my policy
of the entire time I've been here and
I've been the happiest and most
productive part of my career there is
something I wondered if you were aware
of there's something on a on Twitter
called at Thomas soul that you did not
start are you aware of that they told me
that I'm not I don't think
everyone just look at it it he says if
it's a he says I'm not Thomas soul but I
own all of his books and tweak quotes
from them and I'm gonna read back to you
the a couple of the quotes that he has
tweeted out to the followers he's got
some over 87,000 followers
reading your work here's one it just
says most people who read the Communist
Manifesto probably have no idea that it
was written by a couple of young men who
had never worked a day in their lives
and who nevertheless spoke boldly in the
name of the workers similar offs
offspring of inherited wealth have
repeatedly provided the leadership of
radical movements with similar pretenses
of speaking for the people was that your
book on Marx oh I know I would it would
not no I I don't think I would have put
things like that in that particular book
which was really a study of the history
of ideas were you ever a Marxist oh yes
during my 20s fortunately unlike today's
left I never felt that I had to avoid
seeing what people with different views
thought and so during all my years as a
Marxist I read everything across the
political spectrum I have to this day a
book or book that I very first read back
when I was an undergraduate at Harvard
on and I've treasured that book I could
tell even then and so I understood that
there were reasons why people have
different views as I see even today's
that's not just that it's it's the it's
not just just a question of being on the
side of the angels against the forces of
evil
here's another tweet and these are your
words racism is not dead but it is on
life support kept alive by politicians
race hustlers and people who will get a
sense of superiority by denouncing
others as racists yes I suspect that
there are millions of Americans who
would be gratified if the whole subject
of race simply vanished into thin air
those they're sick of hearing about it
but there are people for whom this is
is a very lucrative business I'm amazed
at how little attention was paid to the
fact that al sharpton knows the federal
government billions of dollars in taxes
you don't owe millions of dollars in
taxes unless you've made millions of
dollars in income and the question is
how did this man you know ever get into
a position to make millions of dollars
other than by race hustling one more
tweet you will never understand
bureaucracies until you understand that
for bureaucrats procedure is everything
and outcomes are nothing if you have
been living in a world where outcomes
are everything you may have a very hard
time understanding bureaucratic thinking
or practices yes yes I know from time to
time my wife was amazed at some of the
foolish things that are done by the
government but if you understand
bureaucracy it makes perfect sense that
given giving you example some years ago
I went on a trip in which I was I turned
my expenses over to the University for a
reimbursement and no one in the
university questioned any of any of any
of the major expenditures but someone
decided that I should not be reimbursed
for the collision damage a cost of
renting a car from one of the agencies
because Stanford has a clause that it
covers that and so on and I was so
outraged about that by I went to the
head of the Hoover Institution and he
had better things to do than this and so
he gave me a mid-year raise in the
amount of a collision time he's so hit
so that he could get this video off his
back but those people who did that never
asked you know why did I why was I there
four days for this event and the answer
was I had a lot of other restraints but
I say there's no need to even say that
so long as they have paper they're happy
you know and and so there they seized
upon these little things that are
utterly in concert
and they let everything else go by
you're not that far away from your 87th
birthday what do you intend to do would
do and this sounds like a crazy go ahead
look for the rest of your life what do
you want to accomplish what your so
called bucket list for the rest of your
life
oh I'll be happy if I can finish up all
the things that I have currently going
which will be quite a quite a product
quite a project right now I've already
finished up the third edition of my book
wealth poverty and politics
months ago and my assistants are so busy
that they haven't had a chance to work
on that and trying to put it into print
so you got a book coming out soon not
soon and I don't even have a timetable
because I find the easiest way for me to
work is to tell no one not even my agent
that I thought I what I'm working on and
when I it's all finished and I then send
the finished manuscript to my agent and
then leave leave it with her and she
knows to call me back when she has an
office our guest for the last hour has
been dr. Thomas soul he's sitting on the
Stanford campus where he has an office
but he writes a lot out of his home and
there's a lot to read if people are
interested in reading a lot of your
works or your books and we thank you
very much for joining us thank you for
having me
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
Q&A org Q&A programs are also available
as c-span podcasts if you enjoyed this
week's Q&A interview with thomas soul
here are some other programs you might
like our 2005 interview with mr. soul on
politics his books and his views as a
conservative african-american George
Mason University economics professor
Walter Williams talking about his life
and libertarian views and conservative
radio talk show host Mark Levin
discussing his career his books and
politics you can watch these anytime or
search our entire video library at
c-span org